The Euler's Method applet helps
us understand numerical methods
for approximating solutions
to differential equations.
I can choose the
differential equation
using this pull
down menu, and I've
selected the equation y
prime equals y squared
minus x, the same equation that
we used in the isocline applet.
The graphing window shows a
slope field, the slope field
of this equation.
And the value of the slope
field can be read off
by rolling over the window.
It's read off on the
right-hand side here. f
of x, y is various values
depending on where I'm located.
I've also chosen an initial
condition, initial value,
of x equals-- x_0 is
zero, and y_0 is minus 1.
I can see the actual solution
with that initial condition
by pressing Actual from this
set of boxes and checking Start.
Now a curve is drawn
on the graphing plane.
This is the solution with
that initial condition.
And a table of values shows
up in this left table.
We can see that this is
one of the solutions which
is sucked into the funnel.
So we understand
the values of y of x
quite well when x is large.
But what if I want to
know the value of y of 1?
According to the
table over here,
the value is
approximately minus 0.83.
But how do we know that?
Euler's method is the
simplest numerical method.
It uses the tangent
line approximation.
If I set the step size to be
1, I can then click Start,
and this will draw a tangent
line segment, with delta x
equal to 1, starting at
my initial condition,
and with slope given by the
slope field at that point.
So the tangent line
approximation to y of 1
is the value zero.
Well, that's not very good.
But I can improve things by
using a smaller step size.
So let's go down to a step
size of 1/4, start again.
Now I've drawn a
tangent line segment,
but the horizontal
distance is only 1/4.
Let's see if we can
see this more clearly
by pressing the zoom key.
This will zoom in on the same
picture that we had before.
I can measure the slope
field at the end point
of this green line segment.
It seems to be about 0.32.
And by pressing Next Step,
I can draw a line segment
moving off with that slope.
So this now, it produces a
polygon, the Euler polygon,
which will stay closer
to the actual curve
than the simple tangent
line approximation did.
I can continue this process by
continuing to say Next Step.
The table of values
appears on the left,
and we discover that
the Euler approximation
to y of 1 with step
size 1/4, is minus 0.75.
Much better than the
earlier value we had.
And I can improve
things still further
by choosing a smaller step size.
In fact, you get as close as
you want to the actual solution
by selecting sufficiently
small step sizes.
Let's do one more example
with step size of 1/8.
Now I will click 8 times
to produce an Euler polygon
with 8 segments.
And I have an
estimate of minus 0.8.
All of these estimates
are too large.
All of these curves,
these polygons,
lie above the actual
solution curve.
Let's see if we can
see why this is.
You'll notice that the slope
field is given by the formula
y squared minus x.
So as x increases, the slope
field decreases in value.
So as we're moving out along
one of these Euler struts,
the slope field is
decreasing under it.
And that causes
the actual solution
to fall below the Euler polygon.
And that process will continue
as I iterate the Euler process.
So the general rule is, if the
direction field is decreasing
in the x-direction, you should
expect the actual solution
to be less than
the Euler estimate.
There are lots of
things that can go wrong
in this kind of numerical work.
To see one of
them, let's unzoom.
Zoom back, clear the screen,
redraw the actual solution,
and choose step size 1.
Now instead of wanting
to compute y of 1,
suppose that I wanted to compute
the value of the solution
at x equals 6.
Well if I try doing this
using step size of 1,
let's see what happens.
So I begin.
I have the same
strut I had before.
It's too large, but
now the slope field
has a negative value so
that comes back down.
Things are looking better.
In the next step, I've overshot.
And if I take another
step, then I've
overshot again in the other
direction, more dramatically.
And now the slope field
is even more negative.
So when I take the
next step, I've
overshot yet again,
more dramatically.
And if I take the next step, now
my estimate for the solution,
which is down here, at x
equals 6 is the value 7,
this is in the range where
the slope field continues
to increase forever.
And so my estimated solution
will zoom off towards infinity,
while the actual
curve is down here.
I call this
catastrophic overshoot.
It's just one of a number
of different things
that can go wrong when you try
to use these numerical methods.